I never open any first that way yeah
great big bells ring turn
they're you're a cowboy
and those are the nominee for best
reissue a new category here on gamespot
SAT game of the year awards so folks a
lot of great games came out this year in
reissued form with new modes new
graphics whatever and we ended up
knocking it down to five so for you guys
why do you think a game likes a grand
theft auto 5 do you think that was
enough to get it within this category of
nominees but it was really hard to even
narrowing down the nominees because it's
not just how good was the game when it
came out originally it's what did they
add to it how much wood was layered on
and Grand Theft Auto is just a great
example of a game that is a remaster I
mean it looks a lot better but they
added too much content that you're able
to do things you weren't able to in the
original game they added the first
person mode doing pld let's be an animal
and fly through the air I think if you
talk about looks a lot better grand
theft auto 5 is not the best example I
think like Metro redux yeah fable
anniversary these are games that have
like like entirely new art assets and
just like like with fable you got new a
new lighting engine like all this stuff
that just read Riva faiz these games and
brings them to life in a way that you
know is sort of keeps pace with what
modern standards are and really gives
you a new way to appreciate how friggin
great they are but Lillian was then what
hey any chance i'm gonna throw to you
because your focus is what is that what
is it about pokemon omega ruby alpha
sapphire okay i want to talk about GTA
you like that okay because no i mean
you're talking about you know these
games that like look better right you
know maybe Grand Theft Auto the
graphical upgrade wasn't so big of a
deal but the first person mode totally
changed the way that that game has an
impact on you as a player and therefore
like what you do in that game I mean
things are so much more personal and
brutal for me that that's such a big
impact on my interpretation of what
makes that game special it's certainly a
strong contender but what about hokum
right so it put a lot more personal and
brutal like yeah because this is coming
from you know games that were on the
game boy advance there's a 32-bit system
but it was still too d little sprites
very much in the same vein as the older
game boy game just with color for the
most part
this is taking that game and expanded it
those two games expand them in a 3d
world where you know it's it feels like
a more modern game it is sort of
recreating the old one like almost
verbatim for the story but it adds new
stuff you have these mega evolutions of
Pokemon where you collect these stones
and you get this sort of like one
instance per battle like make a sort of
evolution and it's you know that part's
interesting but it yeah it's like
pokemon for a new generation but an old
game so as a reissue it's great because
it really does revitalize and it's not
even just borrowing what pokemon x and y
did it's doing new stuff as well like
this is almost in some ways kind of a
sequel to those games it had observe the
new features in it a little bit yeah
just kind of treat it that way with the
intro as well which i think it's worth
noting also you guys tell me who the
nominees for this katic to guess who the
nominees for this category are two
months ago there's no way halo the
master chief collection is missing my
nomination for this category exactly so
I wanted to ask you about this is of
course you reviewed the game quite a
tumultuous review process because the
game was just broken each you can't play
that game multiplayer reliably I mean
it's been getting incrementally better
slowly but like by half steps and
sometimes back steps and it's just the
campaign stuff in there is incredible
what they've done with halo 2
anniversary and the campaign experience
all the new blur cutscenes are just
awesome but you got to take the game as
a whole when it comes to these awards
because you're you know an award is a
recommendation is an honor for the game
and to to honor halo the master chief
collection in this category would be to
be basically ignoring the huge problems
with all the multiplayer stuff there
which is a big reason why so many people
were so into that game myself included
and then our fifth nominee Diablo 3
ultimate evil edition and a game which
you could argue that the expansion pack
and then ultimate evil edition arguably
fixed that game oh yeah I think one of
our editors or someone in the meeting I
can't remember who said i can't believe
diablo 3 went from like my biggest
disappointment one year to my favorite
game the next year just because of all
the changes that you know aggregated
over the year and then culminated with
the ultimate evil edition i mean and
plus playing on console actually feels
like you know i played diablo games in
the past and
enjoy them but just the feel of the
sticks deal of them of this on on
next-gen console is incredible and
lastly I guess the last elephant in the
room would be a lot of people probably
shouting in the chat right now asking
where's the last of us whether the last
of us not make it onto the list this was
a point of a bit of contention at our
meeting for sure like I said earlier
like it's not necessarily just how good
the game was originally I mean the last
was remastered is still an amazing
experience and amazing game just like
the last of us but it didn't really add
that much outside of that graphical
upgrade and it's beautiful like I'm if
you didn't play on ps3 I recommend
playing on ps4 and I would play it again
on ps4 like I'm looking forward to
trying it out again I haven't played it
this year but it was mostly just a
graphical upgrade but yeah and I think
there's a key there's a difference here
too when you talk about graphical
upgrades because coming from last year a
ps3 release versus like an Xbox release
with fable anniversary I mean there's
there's way different scopes for
graphical upgrades and for the kind of
work that goes into it and for the kind
of change that that kind of upgrade can
affect on the gameplay and I think what
it came down to for the last of us
remastered is yes it looks a little
better you know yes left behind is
included on this disc and it's a great
deal and it's totally I've highly
recommended but in terms of bets reissue
it just wasn't up to snuff for our
categories exactly hopefully left behind
might get a look in at some states and
the nominees as well I guess we'll have
to wait and find out those are the
nominees for Best reissue the winner of
that will be announced on gamespot com
tomorrow December tense